>From these individual QRDA files,
popHealth aggregates and
summarizes quality metrics.
Here, for example, are 500 patients
from a 10 provider practice,
in which, individual physicians
could be using different EMRs.
This practice might be under
an outcome based contract,
where their revenue is tied to meeting
goals, for these quality metrics.
Here, they're doing well on
smoking screening, but not so well
on weight screening, particularly for
adults in the 18 to 64 group.
This points out the need to identify the
right group of patients for each metric.
For example, you would not normally
perform screening mammograms on men for
breast cancer.
And the recommendations for
this screening are increasingly pointing
to a specific age range for women.
Note that in recognition of this key
point, the numerator, typically,
the number of patients who's care
met criteria is in green for
each metric, while the denominator,
the applicable target patient group for
the metric is in blue.